[MUSIC PLAYING]
MORGANTE PELL: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to OPS210.
We're going to be talking
about infrastructure
as code and how you can do
it at scale as an enterprise.
I'm Morgante Pell.
I'm one of our strategic
cloud engineers
working with our large
enterprise customers
on all of our DevOps
best practices
and how you can really
effectively use infrastructure
as code.
I'm with Andrew here.
ANDREW PHILIPS: Oh.
There was actually two
clickers here, which is nice.
Thanks, Morgante.
I'm Andrew Phillips.
I'm a product manager in GCP
working on continuous delivery.
Long story short, I've suffered
on all sides of the software
delivery space.
I've also been a
head of duct tape,
so hopefully, head of
infrastructure efficiently.
So hopefully have
some good familiarity
with what the challenge is here.
Just a quick reminder.
There's mics here, so
we will obviously be
taking questions live as well.
But if you do have a
question at any point
during the presentation,
you can put it
in the Dory using your app.
And then we will try to
answer them from the floor
and also from the Q&A.
And we'll obviously
get round to any that we
aren't able to answer here.
OK, so let's set the stage here.
What's the actual problem
that we're trying to address?
Well, typically, what
we see quite frequently
is when users, or
companies, or teams
get started with the cloud--
oh, yes, I have access
to a cloud project.
That's great.
And let's follow a
couple of tutorials,
or let's try a
bunch of things out.
And then I copy
paste some commands.
And then I click
around a little bit
to set up some configuration.
And eventually, I have my
POC environment running,
or I've tried a few things out.
And I've got a bunch of
things that I've created,
maybe some networking config,
maybe a couple of clusters here
and there, maybe some VPC stuff,
and then a couple of buckets,
and so on and so forth.
And I mean, there's
a whole bunch here,
some IM permissions.
But it's kind of manageable,
and maybe some of it's
not necessary.
But if I have a few things lying
around, that's not terrible.
And actually, GCP
does a nice job
of warning you about things
that haven't been used
and so on and so forth.
But let's imagine you decide
that you really like this.
This cloud stuff
is great, and you
feel it's going to help
your company a lot.
And then you get all
your development teams
or your friends to work on it.
And then you add more resources.
Suddenly you've got a
whole bunch of projects.
So maybe you want to start
doing some stuff at the more org
level.
I mean org as in
the GCP construct.
So you don't have to set
up the same permissions
or the same policies, these kind
of things, all over the place.
So you've now got two places
where your config is already
living.
And then I think
you kind of know
where this is going,
dot, dot, dot, dot.
Suddenly you're all
in on the cloud.
You've got tons and
tons of projects.
You've got org level config
that's quite complicated.
And you have all these 500
projects, each one of which
is set up, well, similarly,
but then slightly differently.
And some of them are maybe in
compliance and some of them
are out of compliance.
And really, config
sprawl, I think most of us
have heard this term.
We don't want to go there.
If we have been there already,
we want to get out of it.
And if we haven't been
there yet, good for you.
But we're going to talk about
how we can try to prevent this.
What's the answer,
at least what we're
going to be talking
about today is
how we can manage this
complexity with relatively
well-known patterns, thankfully,
so there's nothing too crazy
here.
Using infrastructure
as code and automation
to handle both the definition
and the safe rollout
of configuration to
all the various places
that we need to have in GCP.
And we're going to look
at a couple of tools
to do this, a code repo.
We're going to look
at Cloud Build.
And we're going to look
at deployment templates
here to reflect
the configuration
that we want to have.
So what are some of the
benefits of using infrastructure
as code?
Well, similar benefits to using
any type of configured code.
You've got all the nice bits
about using code management.
Things are versioned.
You have things like
stable IDs through commit,
so that you can always point
back at a previous version.
You can have multiple
people working
on the same things,
et cetera, et cetera.
You have this idea that rather
than infrastructure being
in whatever state
it happens to be in,
you actually have a
place that specifies
what you want the
infrastructure to look like.
And that's useful for things
like drift detection or just
as an audit trail.
But of course,
it's relevant also
for things like disaster
recovery scenarios
if you want to bring back
something to this day
that it was and so on.
It's nice and
declarative, so rather
than hiding the intended state
in a bunch of G Cloud commands
or in a bunch of
imperative commands,
you can actually look at it.
And it's hopefully
human readable,
and it gives you a
sense of what it is
that you were going to set up.
I talked about
auditable a little bit.
And then of course,
it's modular if you
have the right type of conflict
as code or infrastructure
as code tooling or
language that you're using.
You don't just have to have
one enormous flat file that
is copied or duplicated all over
the place, some parts of it.
You have the ability to do
things like inherit sections
so that you can have a
shared definition for maybe
some networking
config that you use
in a whole bunch of
different places.
So we talked about code.
We talked about some of
the benefits of managing
this configuration as code.
And what we've
learned when we talk
about source code
over the years is
that there are certain practices
that are really useful in order
to make sure that
we don't break stuff
when we build applications.
And if we're going to
think through what's CI/CD
or what deployment might
look like for infrastructure
as code, we can use exactly
the same processes by analogy
to think through
what that might mean.
So most of us have probably
heard of continuous integration
for application code,
the idea that whenever
I submit or propose a
change to my source code,
I should run a whole bunch
of tests and verifications
to make sure that
this change actually
is going to be good and not
just eyeball it and think
like, oh, it looks fine.
Let's try it out.
And of course, we can
do something similar
for infrastructure as code.
I'm proposing a change to my
infrastructure definitions,
maybe a change to a firewall
config or something like that.
And automation can give me
a lot of information about
whether that change is safe,
whether that change is good.
At the very simplest
level, automation
can tell me whether I actually
have made a syntax error.
And the new configures code
is broken or is not broken.
And so we'll talk a little
bit about how we can--
what kinds of information
we can feed back
to whoever is working with
the infrastructure as code
in order to make sure that
we have good confidence
that the code change we're
proposing actually works.
And then if we, again, we follow
that analogy a step further,
yes, we've assured ourselves
that a code change or a config
change that we're
going to make is safe.
But now instead of
just saying, great,
let's just apply it everywhere
and see what happens,
what we've learned with
application releases
is that it makes sense to
have a gradual progression,
some process where we maybe
run some integration tests,
or we have a
staging environment,
or we maybe even
do advanced things,
like a blue green deployment.
There's lots of
practices that we've
discovered that make the
rollout of a new config
or a new application
change safer.
And of course, we can do the
same thing for infrastructure
as code as well.
We can think through how we can
safely roll out these config
changes progressively to the
places where they need to go,
as opposed to saying, oh,
I've approved the change.
Now somebody gets their
laptop, clones the repo,
and goes apply or does that in
Cloud Shell or somewhere else.
And as I hinted at when I talked
about the progressive rollout,
one of the dimensions that come
into this is that of course,
we have multiple
environments in most cases.
You don't just have one
set of config for one GCP
project or one environment.
It's very common that as we
think about our infrastructure
landscape, we have this
notion of logical differences.
We have the dev environment,
or the test environment,
or the staging environment for
our teams or our applications.
And we also have
inevitably differences
across those environments.
And so what we want
to do is, A, we
want to be able to
reflect that difference
in our infrastructure as
code, so we can easily
see what the state of our
dev, and test, and staging
environments should be.
And we also want to have a
rollout process that takes
these changes through the
various environments so that we
don't--
I mean, we can if we want to.
But it's often safer rather
than applying the changes
to everything at once.
Let's take an example case.
If you're going to
change a firewall rule,
it's kind of useful to change
it in the staging environment
first to see if your application
still works before you decide
to apply that same
kind of change
to your production environment,
where if you get it wrong,
you might be breaking your
users who suddenly can't access
the application anymore.
So there's a longer--
let me just pause
at this-- there's
a longer discussion
about how environments
map to different GCP projects.
And I think the short answer is
that there is no right answer,
but we are very happy to talk
about different patterns there.
Suffice it to say that from
the perspective of what
we're going to talk about
today, it doesn't really matter.
Your dev, and test, and
staging environments
could all be resources
in the same project,
or they could be spread
across multiple projects.
So having taken these
principles about CI and CD,
let's now look at how we
can actually technically use
tools that are available to
implement this kind of flow.
So what we're going
to have, we're
going to have a code repo
that has infrastructure
as code definitions for
multiple environments.
We're going to submit or propose
a change to this definition.
Or rather, we're going
to work as I just
do the handwaving slide bit.
We're going to have CI,
an automation process,
providing feedback
on that pull request
to tell us about whether it's
a good pull request or not.
And we'll talk
about some tooling
we can use as part
of that process
to give us more
useful information.
Then we're going to
have a review process.
The nice thing about
using a code repo
is that we kind of get that for
free through the pull request
model.
And there's actually
some nice-- depending
on which repository
service you're
using, whether it's GitHub,
or GitLab, or Bitbucket,
or whatever.
Did I say GitHab?
GitHub.
You have nice options about
adding access control,
and you can require that certain
people are the only people who
can do reviews and so on.
Somebody is going to
review this code change
after we've got the feedback for
things like policy compliance.
Then we're going to decide maybe
or maybe not it's good to go.
And then, of course,
once it's done,
we are going to take
this config change,
and we're actually
going to apply
it progressively to the
various environments
that it has to go to.
So what are some of
the design principles,
if you like, in terms
of the automation
that we're going to
be looking at here?
We're going to be
using some release
pipelines to do the automation.
So that's not going to be
somebody following a Wiki page.
That's actually going
to be fully automated.
And again, we're
going to see that we
can store this
automation in the repo,
as well as config as code.
We're going to have
a sort of equivalent
to integration
testing or to testing.
Obviously, for
application code, we
understand what
integration testing means.
But there are analogies for
infrastructure as code as well.
The pull requests give
us a manual judgment,
and of course,
given that we have
the last version of the
config in our repository,
because we're just changing
it in a version store,
we also have a nice vector
to do things like rollbacks.
So basically, I guess
the long story short
is that all the good design
principles about CI and CD
that we apply for
applications, we
are also able to apply for
infrastructure as code here.
So to get a little bit more
detailed, this all sounds,
I think, hopefully very
nice and compelling.
But now you actually
have to make
some concrete decisions
about, OK, I've
got this batch of
infrastructure as code.
I've got multiple environments.
I'm going to roll them out.
How do I reflect that
in my repository?
And again, while
caveating it by saying
that there is no perfect
answer for all situations, what
we're going to present here
is a templated pattern.
Or one particular suggestion
that you can use and you can
think about using
in your setup--
and again, this is not
the only way to do things,
and I'm very happy to
discuss variations depending
on your use cases afterwards.
But we think this is a
really good place to start.
So what we start with is we
have a master branch that will
include in different folders--
yes, we start with
a master branch
that will include
in different folders
the configuration
that we want to have
in each of the
different environments
that we're rolling out to.
Now this means that this
is what we want to have.
This doesn't necessarily
reflect what is actually running
in each of those environments.
But it tells us what
the kind of like this
is what we want to move
towards, and especially
as we make changes
to it, so we might
open a pull request against
this branch, for instance.
To change the information
in the prod folder,
that means that we are
thinking about making
a change to the prod config.
It doesn't mean that the
prod config has changed yet.
One of the things that we've
learned around Kubernetes--
this is very popular,
but in fact, this
can be done with
any kind of system,
is the idea that we have
GitOps or environments as code
as I like to call it.
It's very useful
not just to have
what we're talking about here,
which is that you have folders
that represent
the desired state,
but that you
actually reflect also
inversion control,
what the actual state
of your environment is.
So as we start doing
the deployment,
as we start applying this config
across our various resources
in GCP, we want to have
that actual state reflected
in our repo as well.
Because that gives
us a history of not
just of what we wanted
to happen, but of what
actually happened.
So what you will see is
that the state of master
is intended to reflect the
state of the dev environment.
Right?
So what is in master when
something is in master,
we think that that is what
the dev environment should
look like.
And so the automation
is set up--
you'll see that in the demo
that as we merge changes
into master, the
job is or the intent
is that that should mean
make the dev environment
look like this.
The next stage in
the progression
is once we're happy
with the dev environment
and we want to move
forward, we will
take the staging environment,
the information that's
in the staging branch, and we
will apply that to the staging
environment when it's merged
to a particular branch called
staging.
And then when we are happy
with the outcome of that,
we think everything is OK.
Staging actually looks OK.
The apps are still running.
We want to go forward and affect
our production environment.
We will take the changes,
and we will apply them also
to the prod branch.
And that will show us
what is actually in prod.
So if you look at the
prod branch in your repo,
that will tell you
what actually happened
or what the state of the
production environment
really is right now.
It's somewhat abstract.
And it will become, I
think, much more real when
you see the demo in a second.
And so for that, let me
hand over to the magic
that Morgante is
about to show us.
MORGANTE PELL: Thanks, Andrew.
Sorry, skipped ahead there.
So for my first demo
I want to focus on
is actually the
shared foundations.
That's something we were talking
about that's not necessarily
project specific.
This is things like
networking, billing, IAM,
security controls,
all that stuff
that is shared across
the organization.
Often, you have a
central team that's
running this sort of thing.
And really, it's very
important because it
affects so many different
parts of the organization.
And so many different
applications
can depend on a shared
VPC, for example.
So we're going to show
how you can actually
do that through
infrastructure as code
and have the same
pattern of rolling it out
across multiple environments.
Specifically, using Terraform,
which is a open source tool
developed by our
partner HashiCorp.
It has support from
multiple clouds,
but great support for Google.
And in fact, we actually
have a full time team
of Google engineers
who work to make sure
that there's good support
for Terraform on GCP.
All the same patterns that
we're talking about here
can be used with more or
less any infrastructure
as code tool.
You can use them with Google
Cloud Deployment Manager.
You can use it with Terraform.
You can use it with Ansible.
You can use it with whatever
tool you're using to.
But today, we're going to
be looking at Terraform.
And one of the big things
that it actually has
is different plugins
and different providers.
So the Google provider
is maintained primarily
by Google engineers.
So just to go ahead to
the demo, there we go.
Cool.
So here I have my
deployment repo.
So this is just a simple repo.
It's for my little sample
organization that I have.
And one of the big things
that we have as a principle
is that you actually
want to separate it
out so that you don't
have all of your code
in a single folder for all
of your environments or even
for a single environment,
all the different purposes.
You want to separate that
out by different purposes
and particularly by
different teams that
might be maintaining it.
So often a pattern we'll
see is that there's
a networking team, for example,
that's maintaining networking
config comprised of both
automation engineers,
as well as any
traditional network
engineers that might be involved
in looking at that as well.
So within this
networking folder,
like Andrew was talking about, I
have my different environments.
In this demo, I'm just doing
a very simple dev and prod.
So we can have simplicity
there, where we have
each of the Terraform files.
One of the things you
notice here is we actually
also have some
files on the root.
This is for files
that are shared
across multiple environments.
So I don't have to copy and
paste the exact same file
into each environment.
I can actually have a shared
file and just sim link it
into each directory where
it needs to be used.
And Terraform automatically
can pick those up.
Deployment Manager can as well.
So you can very easily share
code across these environments
if you need to if you
want to have the same file
without copying and pasting.
So let's jump into
dev environment here.
So here are a couple things
that matter in this folder.
Each of my environments,
I want to make sure
that I have a backend config.
This is used for storing the
Terraform state so that I'm
making sure that
every change I make
is actually stored on
Google Cloud Storage.
So I can roll back if I need to.
I have version history there.
If I want to collaborate across
multiple different CI runs,
it actually has
locking in place,
so it can make sure that
two different CI runs aren't
attempting to manipulate
state at the same time,
as well as the ability to
revert back if necessary.
And then I've got
the provider config.
I've got a couple of variables
for things like what my org
idea is, if I want
to be able to have
that be easily substitutable.
And then in my main.tf is where
I start actually configuring
what my dev networking
environment looks like.
As you notice, most
of the actual code
that goes into these
individual environment folders
can actually module or
template reference this.
Because in many cases,
you want to share a code
across different environments.
So you don't want to actually
have all of the config
and all of the complexity be
in the individual environments
with stakeholders.
You just want to have the
configuration, the specifics
of that environment.
So here, I'm using
this VPC module,
which is one of our
open source modules
that we have for working
with Terraform on Google
Cloud, which is used for
setting up a shared VPC network.
So I specify I want
my project ideas.
I specify which subnets I want.
So I want two subnets in here.
I specify any secondary ranges
I want for the subnets as well.
And then this is all, of
course, very specific to the dev
environment.
So I'm not going use the
same IP space, for example,
between both dev and
prod in most cases.
Right?
So this is configuration
that matters, just
the dev environment, but I'm
able to use the same module
in both environments.
Other parts of the configuration
might be even more shared,
where it's the case where you
have the exact same firewall
rules in both environments.
So this is where this shared
firewall rules module comes in.
I'm able to reference
this module.
And just passing the dev
specific information,
like the network name
and the host project,
it applies for my
dev environment
into the shared
modules so I'm not
having to write the
same firewall config
for each environment I'm doing.
So that's just a relative
reference to the same repo.
So it goes up to this
other modules directory,
where I've actually kind
of shared bits of code
that I want to share across
different environments.
It's very easy to build
a module or a template
in both Terraform and
Deployment Manager.
You just create a
file, create a folder.
You have a module instantly.
There's no registration process.
There's nothing
special you have to do.
Any folder with a
Terraform file in it
automatically becomes a module.
So this is my module just for
shared firewall rules here.
Very simple, just has
a couple of inputs
of which project I'm
hosting my network in
and the network
that's on that pro--
that's the name for that
network, which I also
use in the firewall name.
And of course, I have my rules.
Right now, I only have
a single firewall rule,
which allows HTTPS.
But let's go ahead,
and modify that,
and add an additional rule.
Let's say we realize we
actually have to at least sort
of redirect on HTTP because
people are going to our website
and getting frustrated.
They couldn't access it.
So we're going to just
add an allow HTTP rule.
Let's put it there.
And let's just use the same--
we can use the same target tag.
So this config looks good.
And I can be really
dangerous here and actually
just commit it directly
into the master branch.
Obviously, not what you'd want
to do in the real environment,
but we can start
to see and we'll
talk more about how
you can actually build
an overall pipeline for that.
But we'll just say
Add New Firewall Rule.
All right.
And as soon as this is pushed
into the master branch,
Cloud Build picks it up and is
going to start to build that.
Right?
So here you see push
to the master branch.
Deploy networking to
the dev environment.
So we have a Cloud
Build pipeline
that automatically captures
that, runs Terraform
init in the direct
in there to make sure
that all the modules are
downloaded, make sure
everything's in place, to
be able to run everything.
You can see it pulling all
the Docker containers here
to run everything there.
And then actually goes and
applies it to my environment.
So here, we see the Google
provider, the latest version
because I didn't have it pinned,
and then the null provider.
And then we can actually
see what's being created.
So we can see the allow
HTTP firewall rule is
being created in my dev
environment on that project
as I expected.
And we notice we actually
have so many variables get
interpreted, so
dev VPC allow HTTP.
So we had that as expected.
And everything is complete.
All set.
So if I go over here,
go to my firewall rules,
I can see I now have the dev
VPC allow HTTPS and allow HTTP.
But this isn't on
prod yet, right?
Because we only did
it on dev, and we
want to make sure
everything's working great.
We want to make sure we
get a chance to test that.
Maybe we do some
security testing,
make sure that we're not
somehow exposing application
vulnerabilities that way.
But it's only on dev.
Now let's say
everything looks good.
The firewall rule's great.
We want to promote the
same change to production.
That's just the process of doing
a pull request from the master
branch to the production branch.
So I'm going to go
ahead and go to my root,
and create a new pull request.
And so the base I'm still
going to do on my repo.
And I want it to be actually
my production branch, right?
Only change here was
that new firewall rule.
Otherwise, they're up to date.
So we can say, yeah, I'm
going to do this as a release
candidate basically.
Right?
So I'm going to say this is
what I want to move from the dev
branch into production.
There's a pull request
here so there's
a chance for anyone who wants to
give feedback on it, they can.
They can come in and provide any
details they want, everything
there.
Maybe you have to have a
certain number of reviewers
happen on any production push.
You could say that they have
to come into the pull request
and put the looks
good to me for them.
But you can actually
have all your reviews
and all of your
processes in place
just through the pull request.
Because that's sort
of your ability
to have manual judgments
in place, as well as an ACI
you want to run.
Says there's no conflict,
so I can go ahead and merge.
So I'm just in a merger.
And that'll kick off an
additional Cloud Build.
Yep.
So we push the
production branch.
So now we can deploy
networking to production.
It's going to run along.
Do the same changes
there, and in a minute,
it'll show up here with my
new firewall rule there.
One of the other things
you can do actually
is also with the
folder structure
that I was talking
about, you can actually
have different owners
for different folders.
So you can do something with--
most Git systems support
some form of ownership.
But you can basically
have an owner's
file in each of these
directories and similar
to what we did
with Google, where
you can say the networking--
we want our network team
member to give an approval
on any change that touches
this part of the code.
So you can put that
in the owner's file
in the networking folder.
You could have a
different part for, say,
security changes that you
want to have a team there.
So you can have a lot
of configurability
over who has to approve
different pull request types,
based on what infrastructure
is being affected.
Cool.
All right, that's finished.
And there we go.
We have the same
change applied to prod.
We had conference, and then we
had the exact same commit being
pushed into both branches.
So we have full
confidence that we're
having the same changes being
promoted across the lifecycle.
Cool.
We can go back to the slides.
So I mentioned modules.
They're a primary method
of code reuse in Terraform.
I showed the definition of this.
One of the really nice things
is you can load modules
from many different sources.
So you can do it from
a local repository,
like I showed there.
You can pull from
the Terraform module
registry, which is lots of best
practice modules out there.
So you don't have to go out
and write your own module
every time you want
to do a network
or do a firewall
rule, for example.
And you can also pull modules
straight from GitHub, too--
or actually, any Git instance.
So if you have an
internal GitLab repo,
you can easily pull from there.
You can easily share
modules in that.
They're the best way to actually
do code reuse in Terraform.
In fact, we've done something
called the Cloud Foundation
Toolkit, which is a set
of example and sample
modules for Terraform that
represent our best practices
and experience with
Enterprise customers.
So these cover things like
creating your core VPCs,
creating projects
in a repeatable way,
managing IAM permissions,
creating GKE clusters
that are secure and
deployable effectively.
And we have these templates for
both Terraform and Deployment
Manager that you can download
totally open source, all
on GitHub.
And we actually, for Next,
made a nice website for it.
So you can go there, and I'll
have the links to everything.
And it shows you how to use
it and some tutorials there.
The benefit of this
is you actually--
is that you have to discover
all the best practices yourself
and every team that comes onto
GCP having to figure out how
to create a project, you can
just take the modules that has
all the best practices
baked into them,
and you can focus on the
parts that are specific
to your application use
case and what's needed,
particularly for your--
what's different about
your environment,
instead of doing all the
baseline stuff yourself.
We also have some sample
Cloud Build pipelines.
We'll integrate that
into there as well.
And the other thing
we're trying to do
is actually have
secured defaults
for all of these modules.
Because of the way
that GCP is built,
we actually want
that really easy
getting started experience
that Andrew showed,
that you can go on,
start your free trial,
start planning some services,
do a POC very easily.
And that's really
powerful because we
can have that power of the cloud
to experiment and play freely.
But once you start going
to the state where you're
in an Enterprise
use case, you're
doing hundreds of applications,
you're moving entire workloads
over, you want a little bit more
consistency and repeatability.
And you want more
secure defaults.
So that's what we baked
into these modules.
So these are things like
making sure that you actually
don't have internet egress
by default on any project you
create, making sure that you
have GKE clusters by default
or have private IPs, as
opposed to public IPs.
So it's a lot of
Enterprise defaults
that we bake into these
modules as well, just focused
on sort of the
Enterprise use case
where it's the hobbyist
or PSC use case.
Cool.
So I thought I said that
I was doing something
really dangerous earlier.
And in fact, I was when
I committed directly
to production, right?
I able to push that change
directly to development.
There were still
pull requests where
I was going from
development to production.
But ideally, no changes are
made to infrastructure and all
without some CI feedback.
When we were talking about
the earlier pipeline,
we were talking about
having CI, so feedback that
allows you to do
some sort of testing
and sanity testing on your
code before it actually
goes into production.
So that's where having PCI
and Cloud Build comes in
and the ability to make sure
that human error's accounted
for.
We found that the most
common cases of insecurity
in the cloud is
usually because there's
some human misconfiguration,
some mistake or just
simple misunderstanding
of how the--
or even a typo of how
the configure's set up.
It's often easier to
have miscommunications.
Especially when
everything's in code,
the machine is
exactly translating
what you have in the code.
So you want to make sure
that your code is right
before you actually apply it.
That's why it's easy--
and then we also
realize that actually can
slow down cloud adoption.
Especially for
Enterprise customers,
where you if you're worried
that developers could easily
make a mistake,
and do what I did,
and just go commit
directly into master
and have that deploy into
GCP environment, that
can make security administrators
a little bit worried.
You want to make
sure that you have
the right guardrails in place.
You want to make sure that
you have everything you need,
which is why we are introducing
the idea of the Terraform
Vaildator, which can actually
look at your Terraform config,
run policy checks
against it, and determine
whether that Terraform config
violates any of these policies
before any changes are made.
So this allows you to
have confidence in changes
before they're
deployed to production.
Before any of your GCP
resources are updated,
it can actually
look at that config
and give you full
confidence that things
like no external IPs are being
exposed, that your firewall
rules are not too broad,
that whatever policies matter
to your organization, you
can have them embedded
into your repo, embedded
into your CI pipeline,
that you can have the
full flexibility there.
We released this very
recently-- this V0.1,
I would say alpha
software at this point.
But it's very early.
But the idea is also, we're
trying to build a community.
It's all open source, so
everyone can collaborate on it.
It's a CI binary
you can download.
You can work with it.
And the actual policy
library is also open source.
So we've started with a couple
of handful of constraints
that we think are
best practices, things
like not having external
IPs, but we want
to have more of them over time.
And we encourage everybody
to contribute to that
and actually have a full
community driven ecosystem
of policies that everyone
can contribute, share,
and sort of have policy
configuration as code
the same way that we're
talking about Terraform
modules for your actual code.
You can have the
same reusability
there across the board with
the Terraform Validator.
How this actually
works in practice
is as an administrator, you
go to the Terraform Validator
repo, and you say--
oh, OK, here's
the set of available policies,
available constraints.
I'm going to pick these three
constraints that matter to me.
No external IPs, no sharing IAM
resources outside of my domain,
and every project
that gets created
must have a label that's
the cost center for it.
These are totally flexible.
Administrators can define
which ones matter to them.
But you can take it, put
it into your own repo.
So you take the public
repo, fork it, pull it
into your private repo,
and enable the policies
that matter to you.
And then the administrator
says, here's our policy repo.
Developers, anytime you're
going to deploying to GCP,
it has to pass this repo.
If it doesn't, you're
not getting to GCP.
Then as a developer,
I have the flexibility
to actually start
working on code locally
and know if it's
going break policy
before I actually even
submit it to everyone.
So I kind of have a
very fast feedback cycle
where I know I'm breaking policy
before I even submit the code.
Right?
So I, as a developer, locally
write some Terraform code.
I can run the Terraform
Validator locally,
get immediate feedback there.
And then once I submit it
up into a Git repo as a pull
request, I also
get feedback there.
So I can make sure
it's enforced.
Assuming the CI
check looks good,
then I can actually finally
merge into production
or merge into
development branches,
and I have the full
visibility there.
Cool.
The other part of
this is actually
that you take those same checks,
the checks that we were talking
about where you have the
pre-deployment checks as part
of the Terraform, and
those same policy library
can be used with Forseti, which
is our open source security
monitoring product, which allows
you to do ongoing monitoring.
So in case some developer
somehow got console access,
or there's some legacy
infrastructure that
was in place before you had the
Terraform Validator in place,
you have Forseti.
It does ongoing monitoring
against the same set
of policies and just
detection if there's
any violations there.
And we'll send you alerts, put
them into the Cloud Security
Command Center, or send you
email alerts that you're
getting Slack notification.
Make sure that if there's a
violation, you know about it.
And you can actually
remediate it if necessary.
I mean, you can go
in and find out.
But so you have both sides,
the same policy library
use in both places.
So you're both doing
pre-deployment checks
and ongoing monitoring to make
sure policies are in place
before infrastructure is
created and as infrastructure
matures and changes over time.
How the policies actually
look like in practice,
everything is very declarative
in nature, very similar
to Kubernetes-style APIs.
So if anyone's worked
with Kubernetes,
this looks very similar
to a Kubernetes manifest.
So you have in here this is
for an IAM policy member,
so you can say what
constraint I'm using.
So this is the IAM allowed
policy member domain
constraint.
So it's just specifying
where are members
of my organization
allowed to come from,
so what domains are they
allowed to use, right?
You can specify which
configs you want in there.
You can also do targeting.
So you can say that if there's
a policy that you want that only
applies to a part
of the organization,
you can actually
limit that down.
So this policy, we
have it targeting
the entire organization,
or actually,
in fact, all organizations.
But that could just
as easily be targeting
a specific folder or
a specific project
within the organization.
So you have that
flexibility to scope things
down if there's particular
resources that are more secure,
certain environments that have
more sense of data in them.
You can have more restrictive
policies on those,
versus a sandbox
environment where you might
have less restrictive policies.
Similarly, you can
have the exclusions.
By default, there's
nothing excluded,
but if you have, for example, a
piece of legacy infrastructure
that needs to run with an
external IP for some reason,
you can actually scope that down
and put an exclusion in there
for just that project where
that infrastructure is running.
So you could actually have
whitelisting on those policies
as well.
So really flexible.
In all of this code,
it's really nice.
You can just check
this into a repo.
Your policies, you work
on them the same way
you work on your config as well.
You can also do custom logic.
So this is an example
of if you want
to do-- this is the Rego code.
Rego is an open source
policy language,
that you can actually
take that Rego language,
and you can write your
own code policies in it.
So you can say, I want to have
a custom constraint that's
doing something like checking
that my labels actually
match the format for my
naming convention, right?
So you may have an
internal naming convention
that specifies that
every project has
to match a certain
standard, has to have
costs that are embedded in it.
You can just write
some code that
enforces that constraint, embed
it into the policy library,
and then all of your Terraform
code that's getting submitted
and all of your ongoing
module with Forseti
would automatically
pick up that constraint.
So you have full flexibility
to define your own policies.
You're not constrained by
what Google has available.
This is just an example
of some of that logic.
So now let's look at what
that looks like in practice.
Cool.
So we showed this foundational
infrastructure before.
Now I'm going to put
on my developer hat
and start to deploy a VM.
So this app that I'm working on
is only in the dev environment
so far.
I haven't promoted
it to production.
But I just have an empty
main.tf file for it.
So I'm going to go
and edit this file.
I've got my handy dandy VM here.
So there's a couple
of things I'm doing.
I'm just going to create
a simple compute instance
for my backend
service that I'm going
to be deploying
into GCP, specifying
the region, the
project name on it.
One of the really cool things I
can do with having my Terraform
state stored in
Google Cloud Storage
is I can do references
across deployment,
so that even though I'm not
editing the networking state,
I do actually have
to reference it
because I have to know what
subnet to put my VM on.
So I can actually
very easily do that
by referencing this
Terraform remote state, which
goes and pulls from
the GCS bucket,
gets the latest
networking config that's
been deployed into dev.
It actually grabs what
the app subnet ID is.
So whatever expert the
networking team has identified
as this is the
subnet we want you
for your applications on
there, all they have to do
is export that.
And I can just import that very
easily in my Terraform config
without ever having even
made a configuration there.
So this means the next
time for some reason,
I have to change the subnet,
they can easily update that,
and my config automatically
grabs the latest one.
I don't have to worry about
making any changes myself.
So this looks cool.
I'm going to do that.
But this time, I'm not going
to commit directly to master.
I'm going to be a
good safe developer
and start a feature branch.
Cool.
So I'm going to create
a feature branch.
Let's put in a nice
pull request name.
Cool.
And this immediately
kicks off of Cloud Build.
Now unlike our
previous Cloud Builds,
this one is actually
just doing testing.
It's not deploying
anything, right?
So the first thing
it does, it just
runs Terraform init as before.
But it actually
does Terraform plan.
So I can go in here and
look at a plan of what's
expected to be created.
So I can see it's expecting that
it's going to create a Google
Compute instance.
It's going to have these
parameters, what IP forward.
It's going to be
on this network.
You can see which subnet.
So the actual subnet gets
filled in and completed there.
So earlier in my code, I
just have it as a variable.
But here I can see, oh, this is
the us-west1 subnet dev subnet
01.
So I can make sure that-- do a
sanity check there, make sure
everything looks good to me.
And then finally, it actually
passes it into the Terraform
Validator, right?
And uh oh, it found violations.
Constraint forbid
external IP on resource--
resource my frontend instance,
no external IPs are allowed.
So I accidentally put an
external IP on my instance,
even though my organization has
a policy of no external IPs.
Now if this config had
been merged earlier,
I would've accidentally exposed
my network to the internet.
And we could have easily had
a big issue where there's IPs,
I might not have had the
right firewall rules,
I might not have the right
security software on that VM,
and I might be getting
a call from security.
Thankfully, this got
caught before anything
was actually deployed.
And I had the full ability
to know about that.
In fact, the check
failed, right?
So GitHub is not
even going to allow
me to merge that pull request,
except if you're administrator.
Because the check failed because
my policy was violated there,
right?
And I can go back
to the Cloud Build,
look at the details on that.
But having this enforcement of
the policy compliance at the
build stage with the
CI checks that we
were talking about earlier.
Now let's go ahead
and update that again.
Because we want to make
sure that we actually
can deploy because we want
to have a little bit of--
we want to make sure that we
can take off the external IP.
So if I go here,
go to the main.tf
that I have on my
branch, and we're just
going to take off this
access config part.
Because the access
config is actually
what gives it an external IP.
So I can make those changes.
I go back to my pull requests.
It's going to rerun
the CI on it because I
updated my main.tf again.
It's going to do a
new Terraform plan,
so I can make sure
that whatever change
I merge is the latest
Terraform plan so I
have full visibility into that.
And yep, just have
to pull these down.
And you notice how the fact
that access config by itself
automatically gets
an external IP
isn't actually always
entirely intuitive.
So that's one of the
benefits of this,
is that even if somebody
does something like just copy
and paste an example from the
internet that looks correct,
looks intuitive, make sure you
can detect those violations,
and you can detect
misconfigurations
before they're applied.
Cool.
So cool.
I see my Terraform plan,
and no violations found.
Because I don't have
an external IP now.
If we go up here and look
at it, we see, oh, cool,
there's no external IP on this.
There's no access config
for this network interface,
and there's no external
IP associated with that.
So I'm just going to
go ahead and merge
that because I can merge
now because there's nothing
blocking it.
All my policies passed.
And that itself will also
kick off another CI run
to deploy my app to dev.
So I can actually automatically
have my instance deployed,
doing everything just through
GitHub and through CI workflow.
And in a minute, it'll actually
deploy the instance up to here.
Yep, there we go.
My front end instance
is being created.
Can go back to the slides.
Cool.
So that's the demos
we have today.
The key takeaways-- check out
the Cloud Furnishing Toolkit
to get the templates
for Deployment Manager
and Terraform.
So you can get
started really easily.
Check out the
Terraform Validator
to make sure that you
have more reliability
in your infrastructure
as code pipeline
so that you can detect policy
violations before they actually
happen.
And make sure you can
have security by actually
doing Cloud Build pipelines.
So you don't have to do
any management yourself.
Nobody's logging
into any consoles.
I never touched a shell
in this entire demo.
I was just working
entirely on GitHub.
So you can do collaborating
on your infrastructure
entirely through code, note
never touching a shell.
And use of the Cloud
Build pipelines,
so we have example
at these links.
And I think we have a Dory open
for questions if you have any,
as well as we have
mics around here
if you want to walk up
and ask questions, too.
ANDREW PHILIPS: Let's give
Morgante a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]